this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
sunset left tending bar were in watts a
fan-favorite make a man seeing how he
has a tiny fella he asked for his usual
stool to get up on the seat I of course
obliged and they looked a little panicky
very very on edge
I said why you so on edge here let me
get your II came here what's the problem
I said I said well we're creating new
villains for the next Megaman game now
sir
oh that's oh is the most fun I love
seeing what you guys come up with you
guys always come up with great
characters like fan man a tree man and
shadow man all those great characters
and I said yeah I'm you two excited too
but this year we had a bit of a problem
what he says a fan was just a little bit
too obsessed and he's found out where
our headquarters is and it's busted in
but I said well that's no good one don't
you just call security all away sir I'd
like to but he's a little bit of a
celebrity and if we kicked him out of
our headquarters it both look bad on us
who is this guy they said brentalfloss
announcer print applause you may like
the online musician the guy puts funny
lyrics to videogames I said yeah same
one last several G I know he went to the
games but I did it was that obsessed a
says he is I said well what did he want
well I asked him the same question
makeup unsaid and apparently
brentalfloss looks him and says I want
to be a character in your next game
apparently he said it was always his
greatest dream to be a villain in a Mega
Man game I said well maybe I wouldn't be
too bad I mean you know so tying it in
with this new internet fan base and
stuff and he said you didn't hear his
idea though I said okay what was his
idea
they said floss man a man who uses floss
to destroy his enemies his body would be
a giant case of dental floss he would
use the string as like a whip he also
insisted news the first Megaman villain
to show his bollocks it was a nightmare
and I said what okay well why didn't you
just make up an excuse they says that's
exactly what we did do we said onside
but all our villains are already filled
out and we don't have room for another
one and they said he's not leaving
unless he gets to be a villain and make
a madman so we looked each other and try
to figure out what to do finally make
that said I came up with an idea that I
knew had to work he said he wanted to be
a villain in the game if we made up a
villain that was so terrible and so
something that nobody would ever want to
be maybe you would be voluntarily but
also well that's not a bad idea well
what did you put him in that they said
we made a douche man a man dressed as a
gigantic douche we knew that hard to get
rid of him and also did it they said no
he was incredibly excited about it
Hue's even coming up with ideas like
what does the Bill of these are where he
gets his power which into don't ask
where he gets his power so I made up an
excuse I said oh it doesn't look good on
you which it didn't but that's not the
reason we want
so we came up with another idea
inside-out
cactus cost you man so the point would
have to be poking his body and he'd be
an unbelievable pain turns out the man's
a masochist so he loved it
there's other costumes we tried out like
pubic hair man
crucifixion man butt cheek man hell we
even tried Anna Nicole Smith man which I
guess technically could be woman but we
did think of that actually he said
organs or bit of a sausagefest aren't
they but that's beside the point
nothing we did got rid of this guy he
loved every single one of them so we
finally had no choice we had to make him
a villain in the Bank of Man game Nelson
G what you put him in us so we put him
in as Invisible Man account did you can
see can't hear and is so incredibly good
at it that he even has a whole level
that you can't see so you don't even
know you've played through it lizard did
he buy it he said he's an internet
celebrity of course he bought it he said
he want to make t-shirts out of it
except to make it even more clever the
t-shirts will be invisible and you can't
feel it
apparently he posted an ad online and
like half of his fan base wants to buy
one that's
geez not probably not into production Oy
huh Isis well we weren't going to but
then we saw that a lot of this fanbase
is attractive women and you know what an
invisible shirt might look pretty good
on them in fact it seems to be a fad
that seems to be spreading all over the
world now
the latest thing in women's fashion The
Invisible Man shirt brentalfloss started
this whole new craze so I guess it's
ironic he says he came in wanting to be
a villain for Mega Man but by the end of
the day he was a hero to all of us I
just think oh we did go at douche Manor
the idea of everybody wearing that I
don't want think about it he's a little
strange things as a bartender see a wall
street's things at the pixel palace so
I'll see your laws treat things as a
bartender a pixel palace no lie so I do
it